let's let's listen to DeSantis so he uh
he explained exactly why he did this so
here's the thing
these Sanctuary jurisdictions are part
of the reason we have this problem
because they have endorsed and agitated
for these types of open border policies
they have bragged that they are
Sanctuary jurisdictions they attack the
previous administration's efforts to try
to have border security and so that's
the policies they've taken out and then
what when when they have to deal with
some of the fruits of that they all of a
sudden become very very upset about that
uh well what are these people having to
deal with um here I don't see the
sympathy for them and so um you know the
reality is is I think the Border should
be closed I don't think we should have
any of this but if there's a policy to
have an open border then I think the
sanctuary jurisdiction should be the
ones that have to bear that we're not a
sanctuary in Florida and yes we know
people want to come and so the more we
can divert before we even have to get
there is good for our our state why
don't we all just come together
and say the current policy is a failure
any country worth its salt would have
control over its own borders we have too
many Americans dying and this is totally
unacceptable and let's get the federal
government to do uh to to reverse course
you know just on the the tone and the
body language when you're telling the
truth versus lying it's just so obvious
who's in the right here but to his last
Point shouldn't Gavin Newsom even if
Gavin Newsom believes that Cali should
be a sanctuary state in San Francisco we
should just welcome more illegals to
enjoy the the free Fentanyl and
everything shouldn't his frustration be
with Biden first if you're really upset
by illegal immigrants shouldn't it be
that he's upset with Biden and not Ron
DeSantis Ashley
yeah well you know I think he's probably
upset with Biden for the reasons that
Liz laid out and uh he's channeling that
race and I love the Andy Garcia cosplay
that's that's amazing but um yeah I
think we we all are failing the the
country's failing in its duty to secure
its border
um we can all agree that immigration is
an amazing thing for America and and
appreciate it and and also be grateful
for immigrants I'm an immigrant or I was
an immigrant to America
um but that doesn't mean that we should
have lawlessness on the southern border
or any part of the Border we do need a
secure border as any country does and
Biden is not just failing in that he is
willfully neglecting it he has decided
to completely just wash over that entire
issue and what that's doing is creating
chaos creating crisis and uh creating an
opportunity for people like Newsom to
get a message out like that one so I
think in that regard he's probably
grateful to Biden because it gives him a
little bit of a platform a bit of a
plank to run on and a bit of a moment to
become righteous and sanctimonious about
it but um I think you know the buck
ought to stop at Biden but nobody's
holding him accountable and that of
course has to do with media I mean the
media is just not talking about the
issue not talking about the seriousness
and not talking about Biden's duty to do
something whatever policy you want if
you want a left-wing policy or
right-wing policy it's got to be
something but right now it's nothing
right because then the the sanctimony
about it seems ridiculous you don't care
when El Paso Airport is filled or the
Border towns are filled with all of
these illegals but then suddenly when 20
of them show up in Martha's Vineyard you
people all freak out